so your dad was your coach
um you gotta get to meet him tonight oh
great
um he's he's kind of a legend in the
sport so how has your dad helped you as
a coach as an athlete as a human being
throughout the years
number one my dad is the most brutally
honest person you will ever meet in your
life
brutally honest he will tell you a if if
you are fat he will tell you you're fat
right to your face he wants you to get
better he wants you to be healthy yeah
he doesn't want you to die of obesity
right it's just the way he is if you
didn't do well
he will will not sugarcoat it he will
let you know what you didn't do right
and what he's so he's the ultimate
litmus test yes right um
second is
he is the most passionate
caring like deep like always thinking
about
very cerebral very like um studio a
student of the game
somebody who helped me immensely in
divine defining my strategy
um helping me improve and and always you
know look for the what's next
um
in terms of training i think that he's
probably the most brilliant
human when it comes to
preparing an athlete physically not to
say mentally physically for success
when all the chips are down that athlete
will be ready that day and he has a
system of of training and preparing and
getting the athlete to peak for
performance you mean like conditioning
like the whole thing yes
okay because i remember like
vaguely remember
kayla
harrison talking about her preparation
being very difficult yeah
that's it
that's him yeah that's him at the say
you go back and ask ronda rousey about
her career right my dad was her coach
yeah my dad
moved her to camp camp new hampshire in
boston
got her up ran her in the morning had
her downstairs in the basement of his
house training with the weights we
brought a russian girl in she did throws
on his cement outside with the little
crash bag through the russian girl you
know 100 times that morning and then
every night
came to boston you know to the training
center in wakefield trained at night and
went back and slept at my dad's house
and
three weeks straight before she went off
to beijing and he did the same with
kayla he did the same with me like
he's just uh his passion is is producing
athletes the highest level and he knows
how to do it and then
the one side of my dad's um
coaching where i think there's a flora
weakness is on the mental preparation
side of the game he wasn't somebody that
was
um i don't know if he he
maybe because he wasn't an olympic
champion himself and wasn't a world
champion he lacked the confidence
in helping others be more confident so
he's more of a uh
this is what you need to work on type of
thing he doesn't know how to build the
athletes up to make them feel invincible
and i feel like that's something that i
was able to give all of the athletes to
to help them with that visualization
belief in yourself knowing that you're
going to win before you step out of the
mat knowing that we've earned the right
to victory
you know seeing success in your mind
having a positive uh mantra that you i'm
the best in the world nobody's beating
me today type of type of feeling so you
go out there feeling like king kong when
you step on the mat that nobody's going
to stop you you know and so i think the
combination of both of us as coaches
i'm a
a lot more technical my dad is good at
letting identifying what they need to do
for their techniques and what you know
how in strategy how to beat how to beat
opponents and putting game plans
together
um so combined the two of us made a an
unbelievable team so he uh he's not
gonna let the athlete be soft when they
uh when they enter
the highest the most difficult uh
competitions of their career
you